[Musique]
ces célèbres note du compositeur
prokofiev résonne de théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ambiance
angoissante éclairage sombre roméo et
juliette ne sont plus à vérone mais dans
un régime totalitaire des pays de l'est
une des plus grandes libertés celle
d'aimer finalement pouvait être mise à
mal aussi par un régime y pareil et créé
justement un drame d'amour entre deux
amoureux une adaptation de la pièce de
william shakespeare revisité avec le
dessinateur enki bilal ici ce ne sont
pas les familles rivales de roméo et
juliette qui s'affrontent mais deux
classes sociales pour moi roméo et
juliette c'est là en l'occurrence est
plus une lutte des classes qu'une lutte
de deux familles qui seule lui même
niveau social je pensais que la mesure
de lutte des classes pouvait apporter au
niveau dramaturgique une tension
supplémentaire dans le monde ce drame
27 ans après sa création le roméo et
juliette d'angelin presse locale est
toujours réclamé par le public une
oeuvre ancrée dans une époque qui
continue de fasciner
je considère que ce qui réactualise une
oeuvre quand on dit elle n'a pas pris
une ride je pense plus que c'est les
danseurs d'aujourd'hui qui réactive
cette oeuvre qui lui vaut qu'ils font
qui lui donne une cure de jouvence
une création où l'atmosphère pesante
laisse parfois place à la célébration de
l'amour
[Musique]
à